thanks very much i'm carlos busabante
with et canada good to see you both
phenomenal phenomenal performances in
this beautiful movie there's so it says
so much about loss and grief uh did you
learn anything about yourself with
regards to that when you were making
this
always don't you always i mean
i don't i don't know what i wouldn't
know jody i don't know about you i
wouldn't know what to
how to articulate what i learned about
myself but i i think yeah if you if you
if you go and work on a film for two or
three months in a film that means
to you what this film i feel meant to me
and i know it meant a lot to jodi and
the others that were part of the
collective that came together to tell
this very intimate story i think
inevitably you do learn
things about yourself and about your
hopes and about your fears and
you know i mean a lot of the stuff that
is explored in the film as i said before
things that i contend with you know as a
as a father as a as a friend as a
brother as a you know
things
yeah i think
you know
also something that we talked about in
the last junkie that we did is just how
much space coconutty gives you to bring
whatever is happening internally for you
into this and so you know for me this
was kind of the first time that i had
that experience where
you know you're literally bringing your
your whole self and infusing whatever is
happening internally for your character
with whatever is happening internally
for you and
and i think that you know in and of
itself was a learning process um i
certainly learned a lot working with
colin
um it's it's you're lucky when you get
to work with someone who just makes you
want to watch what they're doing and
you get to learn something and and so
yeah i mean the lessons absolutely
abounded
um
malaya told me that um
she was the best at doing that dance
number like that she learned
could it just help
the dancing the acting
the press
she's so articulate she's got such
interesting ideas about the story and
she's she's
incredible she's a born performer she's
a born performer so you know she has
there's and there's just there's no i
feel like there's no self-conscious
about it at all she's really cool and
she's generous of spirit you know honest
to god like i mean i i get
i i feel funky when we talk about kids
and as actors and
how good their performance is and you
know we get into that seriousness in
relation to and i love children and
stuff but it can all get a little bit
serious and um
and i i i just you know
child actors it's a lot grown-ups lose
on film sets i mean grown-ups get caught
up and and and for so for a child to go
through the
the attention of it and and the feedback
and the positive reinforcement or the
pressure of it it's a lot for a child
it's a lot for grown-ups as i said
sometimes so but i so i'm always
suspicious about
child actors and i always kind of
suspicious about the parents and all but
i found myself looking at
malaya and looking at her mom and
meeting her dad and her brother and kind
of going for the first time ever and
i've worked the kids going i actually
think this is really what she's supposed
to be doing
yeah you said that so many times and we
were like i remember you telling me that
even when i was obviously when i got
there you'd already been working with
her and you were just like this
girl like she's meant to do this
for whatever reason she can handle all
the chaos and the pressure with great
grace and she doesn't feel like she's
losing her childhood she's still very
playful and but when it comes to do the
deal she's she's there you know to kill
it but yeah i
she's cool man i wouldn't have any
concerns about her malaya she's
wonderful
that's awesome well i have to say uh i
love the film uh and again fantastic
work both of you all of you really in it
thank you so much for your time today oh
my god that was short
thank you